un entrenamiento para sobrevivir a la
violencia estos niños en el barrio
caraqueño de petare no realizan un
simulacro de terremoto o incendio
aprenden a salvarse de las balas
somos una comunidad vulnerable
donde la violencia es el pan nuestro de
cada día y entonces hay que así conforme
vamos a leer escribir También tenemos
que darle herramienta a los chicos para
que puedan defenderse y aplicarlas en
casa la tasa de muertes violentas en
petare es de 80 por cada 100.000
habitantes es casi tres veces más que la
ya alarmante cifra nacional que a su vez
supera seis veces el promedio mundial el
simulacro es impulsado por el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja dura 20
minutos Durante los cuales los niños
deben arrastrarse hacia espacios seguros
y finaliza con tres campanadas pero se
repetirá cada dos meses porque la
violencia no para ustedes saben que aquí
hubo una temporada muy mala creo que en
el 2020 en donde estuvimos cinco días
este tiroteos intensos con armamento que
parecía esto Afganistán no la inusual
capacitación ya ha salvado vidas
entonces claro cuando llegan aquí ellos
ellos uno decía estos días me agarró y
yo iba por la calle y yo apliqué lo que
me enseñaron aquí en comportamiento de
seguros Y yo qué hiciste bueno tirarme
el piso rodarme y meterme debajo en un
carro los niños están tan habituados a
las balas que saben distinguir el sonido
de armas de distintos calibres pero los
días más violentos asiste a clase menos
de un tercio de los escolares del
colegio Jesús maestro lo que se ve es
que el árbol la ley la pone el arma y
eso es lo que hay que luchar porque el
niño no lo ve así en las aulas los
petareños aprenden a vivir en guerra
mientras se alcanzan los sueños